[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
i want winners 30 to one you hit it you
called it on the show
i'm happy my bank account's tab i'm
giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many hoodies are you giving out today
like 45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together
we have somebody here who likes to face
the group chat you guys are the
absolute worst put some bleeping respect
on my name
why are you even in this group chat
you're not even betting and now you're
gonna tell me i'm wrong
you have no original taste get him out
again i don't want you in here get out
of the group chat goodbye
[Music]
you just joined the vr chat
we've got locks we've got hoodies we've
got
nba finals fever and we also have to
check in
on mikey's mustache recovery it's not
looking good okay
i am burnt alone it's way too soon greg
iver
mikey locks and cabbie richards we are
giving away hoodies all show
so fire off your takes in the comments
and yeah we're going to be talking odds
to win it all for the nba finals
before we do we have a very special
announcement to make
our first ever br betting ticket of the
week
we've been asking you to send us your
tickets we tell you we're giving away
hoodies
and other than mikey locks we like to
keep our promises around
here also mikey boy
and this week's winner is a ticket you
see it there from at nick
scholes nick predicted this is zach's
finals match up back on july 1.
he bet 240 at 25-1 on fanduel
big nick energy eight over 6k
let's go congrats we are sending you a
hoodie
on top of the sixth street one so keep
sending us your tickets we love to see
you win
especially mikey who has never seen a
winning ticket of his own
you you need to chill out okay true he
hit patrick mahomes last night hey
patrick holmes what i'm saying
i need to be an adult and grow up like
nick schultz because he's betting
2 40 on a 25 to 1 bed i'm out here with
a 10 to 20
sprinkle at the end of the day and
living in your parents house mikey it's
time to grow up yeah
anyways the flippers lost
house and move it okay we're not going
to get into it
well no one feels bad a tough week for
mikey locks a very tough one i don't
feel bad for him no one should
we gotta talk about this series who is
fired up
who has a good take about who is winning
it all
we got the lakers we got the heat who's
taking this thing home
guys this is a very short conversation
okay
when it comes to and i'm gonna do my
best mikey locks
when it comes to the nba finals that's a
terrible impression
only mikey locks can do it but guys this
is a short conversation
we love narratives we love legacy
lebron james after watching the last
dance documentary
is super inspired to go out and win his
fourth nba championship
the two best team just two best players
in this entire series are on the same
team and that's the lake show
and listen we can the next five are on
the miami heat
hold on hold on kels and we cannot
heavy we have to properly
[Music]
okay you have to take into account kobe
abbey
passing as as part of the narrative of
the los angeles lakers
winning their 17th nba champion
i don't even know if i can go next now i
mean
geez cabbie but i'm rocking with the
miami heat here
they have the veteran presence of andre
igor dalla who's
this will be his sixth nba finals
shout out to the warriors of course uh
he will have his
his number retired in san francisco uh
but also they have
jimmy butler who is a dog but he's a
really
good dog he's doing his thing leading
this young team
they have bam adebayo tyler hero gordon
dragons jay
crowder i mean do i need they keep going
this this team is
full of ballers they're young
they're hungry they're ready something
like
that
let me go here i've been really
crunching the numbers my algorithms
my projections etc have plus 250 on
miami
in the bubble some you know variance
there as good
value the projections say it the model
says it they have it at you know it
should be around plus 220 so i'm taking
kelly that 30 cents a value per my
spreadsheets algos models
i'm taking heat okay
so mikey just tried to pretend like he
took a stats class in college and used
every single
term he could possibly think of i bet
you did
listen this is tough um we all know i
have a 14-1 miami ticket in my pocket
and no i don't want to hedge it
but no absolutely not are you getting
value with miami here i've told you guys
the lakers gonna be a four five dollar
favorite in this series
no i'm not hedging my bet yes i'm taking
miami
i do think that the lakers are the
better team i do think they're gonna get
all the whistles i think they're gonna
get all the calls
but i got 14 to one mikey shove that
value up here
i think we're just using different i
think we're using different models the
spread the projects are saying
sorry let's go kelly also
you're already making excuses about the
refs the whistles
who cares season one episode one of the
group chat i was the only one who bet
the lakers
to win i was on the lakers too you give
me nope not it you need zero
you're a fraud you owe me five dollars
i'm on the lake they're still
they're going to win greg what are the
people saying in the comments
i'm in the comments and they have some
funny takes here i got
not rudy gobert he says what i want
heaton7 what i think lakers in five
guess what rudy gobert not rudy gobert
i want heaton seven two so you're gonna
walk away with a hoodie
um a new g24
honestly i feel like the heater gonna
pull this off
lebron's needed the weapons that the
heat has 80 is good
but can he put up with the weapon i
wonder if he can put up with those
weapons too
but guess what you're also walking away
with a hoodie i got one more for you
vern
it says uh lakers in five if you think
miami you're delusional well guess what
mets are mediocre i'm delusional
i really think are you getting a hoodie
i'm gonna graze somebody ripping on burn
out of a letdown no no one would rip on
me they're ripping on you
for being dumb greg what do you have d
greg he can bait legend
my guys okay all right let's move on
who's winning mvp at the finals here we
got the odds
coming up right now who we taking
there's a lot of
our favorite word there's a lot of value
toward the bottom
this is this isn't even the question
right here vern
i mean look at the bottom of the screen
look at the bottom of the screen
andre iguodala that's what i'm rocking
with
he already andre iguodala
yes andre iguodala former
former finals nba on former finals
nba mvp uh andre iguodala that's who i'm
talking about he's done it before cabbie
and he's going to do it again
oh honey it was play defense on lebron
jimmy cabby let's have you talk to me
because there's a value here
all we talk about is value this is
understood
thank you mikey thank you mikey greg
malcolm ivory you are a wonderful young
man and you have a promising career
in broadcasting i don't think your
career is as
promising as a better if andre iguodala
is your pick
to an nba finals mvp he's done it
in a series lebron james anthony davis
jimmy butler and
bam out of bio plus 10 000. he's only in
his third year
guys of a 90 year old man
all right i'm now in here
one more thing one more thing locks one
more thing locks
the finals that andre iguodala won mvp
uh lebron averaged 37
11 and 9. cabbie
you have to do is google andre iguodala
next to his name
he has a finals mvp entrepreneur
we're talking about this way too much
it's a fine bet it's a good dart throw
he's not actually gonna win it at plus
ten thousand but greg i like the value
i'm yes he is my stop talking
mike he likes anything plus ten thousand
there's like a meme out there i forget
which show
lebron minus 165 if you think the lakers
are gonna win at minus 370 which a lot
of people do
you take lebron at minus 165 talk about
value
if the lakers win which they should he
is going to win mvp
you know he's already been he's already
been getting the clout going he's
sitting there
you know after making sure the picture
gets taken of him where he looks super
locked in
he's doing that on purpose the man is on
a mission to try to beat mj that's all
he cares about
and i think the voters will side with
him if the lakers win
no mikey is absolutely right this is a
better bet than actually taking the
lakers for the series
no he's actually right you just see
you just took the heat right so why
would you take the heat and then the
lebron at minus 165. explain it to me
because that's a better price than
taking it ahead of a head scratcher
but mikey locks i'm gonna join you in
the double dutch okay it is
it's about lebron's legacy my guy has
taken so many shots because of that
michael jordan documentary
in the in the summertime and but he is
so aware of
everything his image his brand his
legacy there's
no way that if the lakers win the
championship
that lebron james will not be named
finals mvp
he is a distributor he is a rebounder he
plays great defense in the clutch
and he can score at will going downhill
it's
all about lebron for finals mvp in 2020
book that all right who wins mvp the
leader of the team
usually wins mvp not always the best
player but whoever
is the leader who's the leader of the
miami heat that's right it's jimmy
butler
he got no respect the last two teams
guess what
jimmy butler put some respect on his
name plus 750.
i'm with the heat so i have to have a
correlated bet
mikey law it doesn't make any sense
i get if you like the lakers then you
take james 165 but at least
my mvp goes with my bet jimmy butler
plus 750.
you know all of our mvps go with our
bets except for mikey
i am taking anthony davis stats will be
stuffed he will be the difference maker
and he is going to show out for his trip
to the finals
a d mvp plus 300.
greg can i just say something when you
ask me who to pick
for the finals i i i think you guys know
this by now
i like to bet on what i like to root for
i bet on my home team i'm a bad guy i
hate the lakers so i'm not gonna bet on
the lakers i can't go
five six seven games rooting for the
lakers i'm taking the heat
with my heart vern you know that but
lebron minus 165 compared to minus 370
for the lakers win that's a that's a
steal and a lot
i it makes no sense it's not a six
second
i mean it makes perfect sense it's
making a lot of sense in here i'm zach
alfonacus
greg craig what do you have in the
comments
they're in the comments i'm getting all
type of stuff in the comments i got
anonymous source you guys sound like
experts who picked the ravens to beat
the chiefs keep the hoodie
wow but guess what today's a new day
today's a new day
and guess what we're not going to keep
the hoodie so send us your anonymous
address and we'll give you a hoodie i'm
moving on j-rock 8480
draggage for mvp i like that that's
value we're going to give you a hoodie
j-rock doesn't even start
games my guy m tuck cabbie
crapping on iggy get him greg i'm going
to get him
m-tuck just because my guy andre
iguodala
is going to walk away with mvp you're
getting the hoodie uh hopefully he does
walk away with mvp
so you're also you're getting the hoodie
m tuck burn
what talk to me all right well how many
games we got in this series we're split
across the board
what do we have here for this series do
anyone have a strong take how many games
we're going
look it this it's this simple vern it's
this simple
we saw a gentleman sweep against the
portland trailblazers we saw a gentleman
sweep against the houston rockets we saw
a gentleman sweep against the denver
nuggets we will see
a gentleman sweep against the miami heat
it will be lakers
in five because of this reason there is
championship pedigree
on this team javale mcgee quinn cook
rajon rondo
danny green lebron james those are five
dudes that have championship rings
lakers in five what is a gentleman's
sweep i missed that i've never even
heard that before
it means they let them win one game
mikey yeah thank you
mikey doesn't they give them one game
look i'm taking six i'm telling you
mikey stop it
i'm taking six games i don't think it's
going to be a gentleman's sweep i think
the heat are going to play their
proverbial butts off
in this series i think they are going to
give the lakers all
they have win or lose i think this one
goes six games
mikey kelly cabbie vern
let me tell you guys this one's gonna go
down in history
it's gonna go seven it's gonna go seven
they're we're we're in uncharted
territory we're like we're in the bubble
we've never seen this before
so i think this series is gonna go down
to the wire
seven games miami's gonna pull it out
uh i'm riding with seven games here
let's go mikey
is with kelly i am riding with cabbie
all right
cabbie and i go burns we are an absolute
log stack on
on this series i i told people six
no it's going five we're going five
games ignore the words
that's what's going to happen lakers won
this thing easy and then we all start
switching gears to other sports that's
it mikey that's it super strong
super super super strong like my lakers
tick
my like my lakers pick episode one
strong
you have no come back greg go to the
comments
you're just embarrassing the
embarrassment of the comments vern
jc for the win says heat and seven all
day
guess what look at my graphic it says
seven games and i want the heat
so you're getting a hoodie uh casa bio
i think that's your user name lakers and
five
fuzz show so just because you said [ __ ]
show i'm gonna give you a hoodie just
but that's probably not foot show though
just to let you know uh i got i got
jlai 42 six games hero
and duncan robinson gonna win one for
the heat
i like that i'm seeing a lot of splash
bros i'm seeing a lot of mixed
mixed pics in the comments i'm seeing a
lot of mixed fists in the comments
i saw that on social what
forget it here we got game one coming
what's our favorite bet what is our best
bet for game one
we're gonna tell you our favorite picks
and our favorite picks for first bucket
but let us know in the comments what we
should bet together
as a family all right does anyone have a
favorite bet here from game one
greg i'll start it off i'll start it off
favorite bet game one we just got done
learning what a gentleman's sweep is
cabbie gave us the explanation
the lakers are known for dropping game
lebron james historic he's known for
that first game and dropping that first
game
i see miami heat plus four and a half
here take the safe bet
sprinkle some on the money line but i do
see the heat coming out
and uh punching the lakers great
correlating bet great great for lady bet
mikey let's hear your correlating bet
i don't even know what that means stop
saying correlating that doesn't make any
sense to me i have a bet
that will hit it's time to start
throwing darts i'm tired of taking sides
against the spread vegas is right on it
you saw in monday night football last
week
i'm done with it i'm going to start
taking darts and props lebron
triple double plus 260 in game one i
think he's gonna come out firing
and he's already been putting up these
huge numbers all playoffs i think at
plus 260
double up your money and then some let's
get rich
oh i love that mikey lux he's got 27
triple doubles
in his playoff history the record is 30
for magic johnson
that is definitely in his sights listen
but since
since uh g-money has introduced us to
the tenney the race to 10
i'm going to be tailing the lakers race
to 10. they've done it 12 of the 15
games
they've had in the playoffs so i'm just
gonna ride that train
lakers first to 10. i need that action
asap
give it to me right in my eyeballs oh
oh kelly feet i couldn't do a needle so
this is all i could do into the eyeballs
i didn't want to
yeah thank you i need that action asap
i'm gonna put this out there i don't
love a side
in game one i really don't if if i was
getting six with miami i'd be all over
it
and that's what the line really should
be five and a half six but a ton of heat
love
coming in over 60 of the tickets on
miami does
make me super nervous and what did i
tweet the other night you can almost not
bet and under right now in the nfl and
nba nba yes you did the late
under came in last night if you were
late to the party you got beat
i'm gonna wait until right before tip
right now i'm sitting at 2 17 and a half
if i can get 218 218 and a half
i'm going to hammer that under and that
is because
all we've seen is these games flying
over everybody can't wait to bet the
overs
vegas is coming for you boys and i
cannot wait wait we're in chicago
no no i want to hammer the yeah it
sounded super lucky the way you said
you convinced me like maxi waxy
especially weshy
kelly yeah i think it might be a maxi
whale smash yeah what do they say on
twitter
we'll see it maybe like three units
we'll we'll see how it plays out would
you call it a lot
i've never used that word in my life all
right i'm gonna keep my pick
really simple for the mikey locks of all
of us
all right it didn't even make sense i'm
keeping it simple for mikey
lakers minus five idiots they're good
first game
exactly lakers minus five they're
now it's four and a half even better
we're taking the lakers they're winning
games
even better the bookmaker's just gifting
it to you vern even better
i am smarter than them that's just what
it is
thank you for understanding greg the
people are smarter than i like your girl
robots
thank you the people are smarter than
most of us maybe not kelly maybe not
kathy
what are the people saying in the
comments
they're in the comments uh k von 28
heath four and a half eight plus four
and a half is a hammer lock for sure
lakers lose game one all the time
hero goes off leading the heat to a game
one
dub i like that basically what i said so
you're getting a hoodie
uh donk 25 is riding with the over he
said over
217 and a half uh i like that so i'm
gonna give you a hoodie i got
one more going against jay sage one
jay sage one lakers love dropping game
one miami's taking it
plus four and a half is a lot
yes i like it this graphic right here
i like the confidence all right we got
game one quick hitters coming mikey
you've poisoned us today you've poisoned
all of us with your bad picks
and you've poisoned us lately except for
last night that was a nice pick
we need your help in the crowd we gotta
talk about our favorite quick hitter bet
the first bucket we're gonna pitch our
locks to hit the first bucket game one
you are to tell us though who we should
bet
we will ride this together all right so
you guys tell us in the comments
we'll ride it together family bet coming
right up
mikey lead us off this is your specialty
okay oh
now it's my specialty now you want me to
lead you off i've been sitting here
all day just taking it left right
getting jabs
all day and now first bucket comes
because you know i'm the prop guru
nur fees first touchdown for booze first
baskets and now it's like mikey luck
let us know what you like after all day
it's disrespectful
and i'm all the way here i didn't get
off your chest get just
a load on us my dude all right here's
your luck i got you
jimmy butler is plus 750 he is the
heat's best
player and he does not have the best
odds to score you're getting him
at value per the projections at plus 750
he hit the first bucket
in one of the games versus celtics i
think he's gonna come out
trying what did greg said he's a dog
he's their best dog and he's going to be
hunting for baskets
he's a top dog hey mikey i'm i'm going
to stick with you on miami
right right there listen uh on fanduel
on the fender sportsbook it's first
points
not first basket so if it's the first
points
i'm gonna go with bam at a bio because
like we saw in the western conference
finals
frank vogel puts dwight howard out there
dwight howard is
very aggressive and he's going to try to
set the tone fouls bam out of bio
goes to the free throw line books free
throw number one
books free throw number two you can book
that plus 700.
that's where i'm rocking for the first
best very specific let me tell you guys
let me tell you guys what's gonna happen
i've been
studying up on these first baskets uh
ever since you know since we we started
it on the show i've been i've been
really
waiting for these playoff games to put
this one in
and so i studied this one up really
really good my guy
duncan robinson's going to get the ball
off of the screen
he's not shoot the three assists from
jimmy butler
splash plus 700
lock it in let's go i like it
they always run the play for duncan
early to get them going to get those
threes
uh see him to let him see the ball going
through the net so i'm rocking with
duncan robinson i got to take a long
shot here
a little page out of a little mikey
locks booklet that i've seen
and that's just because look you can get
four to one with lebron or a.d
but that's not any fun and i'm sure that
one of those guys will probably score
the first basket
or the king of the assist himself may
kick it to one of his key guys
named kcp plus 1300 kcp
kicks it to the outside nice little
floater i got to take the 13 to one here
let's have fun out there i love it i'm
going to that's value i'm going to take
a page out of the mikey locks handbook
danny green 13. they're all taking my
handbook
there it is yeah now you come to the
hamptons
it's very lengthy a lot of pages a lot
of chapters
a lot of ends a lot of outs a lot of
coloring between the lines
that's what it is uh danny green 1301
he's gonna have an open shot he's gonna
hit it he's been there before
i like him to show up this whole series
i'm on danny green
now it's time for you guys to tell us
who we should bet
i hope you're riding with one of us
probably kelly
but tell us who it is who should we
doubt it our audience hates me after
this
this football weekend it was a tough
weekend greg
who's the winner
[Music]
you know what vern i'm scrolling through
the comments
and um i don't mean to brag but i'm
seeing a lot of
duncan robinson
we need someone else to verify that uh
it looks
like we're rocking with my guy my guy
my god duncan robinson is what we're
riding with as a family
yeah that's right that's who we're
riding with that is the room
all right and then we will
give you yes you're going to go stacy
duncan robinson there's some value on it
plus 650 kelly is that value
is that is that value kelly i i'd have
to look and see what his true odds were
but i i feel like that's probably close
okay all right let's remember what we
all taught you here today
one the miami heat are not a value bet
right now
thank you kelly number two andre
iguodala is winning
nba finals mvp thank you great
and we are hammering duncan robinson to
score the
first basket today as a family
everyone's doing it even kelly's doing
it we're gonna get rich on it
shout out duncan robinson and if you
want a hoodie today
we're gonna dm you now we're leaving the
chat
peace that's that's what we learned hey
that was i'm not
[Music]
you